hey guys welcome back to the channel
today we're gonna be talking about
modern architecture
okay all right today we're gonna talk
about the new macbook pro and the m1
processor and the m1 ecosystem we're
going to talk about the design the
functionality we're going to compare the
m1 air and m1 pro software compatibility
and whether it's worth the hype and the
money and how it compares to the rest of
the industry i'm basing my analysis on
my personal experience with these two
laptops and my personal workflow
preferences
with a focus on architecture and the
creative industry
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dammy and i'm
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc
on this channel we talk about
architecture and design as well as the
tools that can help us live more
creative and productive lives
if you want to check out some of my
other videos i also have videos on
brutalist architecture or on the concept
of experiential impoverishment
and i also have some videos on my
architecture projects
slick powerful nerdy bulky laptops intel
amd apple silicon the last couple of
years have been really good for the
computer industry with so many different
players the markets become insanely
saturated with new laptops from
different brands and different price
points and like i've said before
a laptop is a tool after all that's why
when we buy a new device
especially as architects or creative
professionals we should make our
investment decision based on these two
things
what type of work we do
and how we like to do that work
aka we have to make our decision based
on our workflow so i was given the
macbook pro from apple as a part of
their professional
creative test program
and they basically let us use it with
the goal of getting feedback so that i
can help them improve the computer
features and kind of help push the
industry for further software
optimization this video is not sponsored
by any brand including apple and it's
only just my personal opinions on it so
yeah let's get into it
apple moved away from intel chips that
the cupertino company's been using in
max since 2006. the m1 is the first
apple designed system on a chip soc
that's been developed for use in macs
soc processors in mac products
it's the first real innovation since the
introduction of the x86 architecture but
arm processors are not new
they're responsible for pushing the
smartphone industry over the last decade
because they're extremely good at
solving two problems at the same time
power efficiency and performance the m1
chip has a unified memory architecture
that lets the cpu gpu and other
processor components talk to each other
seamlessly using the same data pool this
increases speed and power efficiency
compared to having all of these
components separated
like in the traditional systems or the
x86 all of these amazing features do
have two minor hardware limitations
there's no support for external gpus and
the other thing is that none of the
components are upgradable which isn't
too much of a surprise since for the
last two or three generation of macs
they already had most of the components
embedded in the motherboard when you are
about to purchase a macbook you do need
to choose the amount of ram beforehand
and kind of be satisfied with that
because that's the thing that you're
going to have to live with for a long
time but the biggest factor in
determining whether these machines can
or can't outperform the x86 counterparts
is the software optimization because
it's only if the software is fully
optimized to run natively on an m1
system that you can experience the full
power of the system
i'll dig a little deeper into this a
little later in the video so make sure
you watch till the end
[Music]
these macbooks are definitely
very well designed machines
and their aesthetics actually didn't
change that much in the past 10 years
this is my old 2012 macbook pro by the
way still fully working even after i
poured beer on it smashed it on the
ground and even slept on it and this is
the new m1 air
and this is the new macbook pro m1
competition tried new designs uh
multi-monitor configurations hinges with
rotating displays you know over the
years the designers at apple they spent
most of their time smoothing out and
perfecting the same design over and over
again
at certain points they were criticized
for putting out the same looking
products and of course that didn't
really matter with their very loyal fan
base with the introduction of apple
silicon they finally made a pretty
radical change to the thing that
actually matters the most the inside
so what's the main difference and which
one would i choose now
the m1 air only has two thunderbolt usb
c ports and one audio jack and that's it
considering you have to use one for
power
unless you have a usb hub
you only have one available usb c port
the air still does have a really
beautiful bright high-res 13-inch
display and it only weighs 2.8 pounds
which is
perfect for me the soc consumes very
little power
which allows a laptop to last more than
10 hours even when you're watching a
movie or using more power training
software and since it's fanless it's
also completely silent
so
no more awkward moments when you start a
presentation
this is a great laptop if you're always
on the move or if you don't really like
carrying big things or if you have
really small hands it doesn't have a
hdmi port so you have to rely on the
adapters if you need to use an external
monitor i actually made a dedicated
video about the m1 air i'll leave the
link to the video right here if you are
interested in buying an m1 air i think
the usbc hub is essential because it's
going to give you
all kinds of additional connectivity
like
usb 3.0 type a ports an external output
for monitors sd card readers ethernet
ports additional power delivery port i
actually currently own three different
usb c hub models that's connected to my
permanent setup so i'll leave the links
to those in the description below
alright so let's talk about the bigger
brother
the new m1 pro
processor
apple went back in time and they used a
very similar poor configuration of
something like 10 years ago
max safe is back so you don't need to
sacrifice a usbc port anymore for
charging by the way yes you can also
charge your laptop with the usbc port if
you want it also has three thunderbolt 4
ports and one sd card reader which
personally i appreciate a lot because i
use my sony dslr camera to shoot my
videos and these cards are still pretty
common in the video and photo industries
it is significantly heavier but also
sturdier than the air
and depending on what you're doing the
battery lasts even longer reaching up to
20 hours the pro model also has a fan
but even when it was running at high
speed it was one of the most silent
machines i've ever experienced the
bigger 16 inch display has a wider color
gamut and even higher resolution
compared to the air
with the only caveat being that it has a
notch at the top it also has a full hd
camera with a wide aperture and
computational image processing that
works directly with neural engine the
speakers are awesome and both models
have a great comfortable keyboard and a
fingerprint reader spec wise the m1 air
offers up to 8 core cpu and 8 gpu the
pro model has up to 10 core cpu and 16
core gpu
and the m1 max model has maximum of 32
gpu cores and 64 gigabytes of unified
memory and both have dedicated hardware
features for video encoding
i think the most important question is
whether the m1 error and m1 pro are able
to run software faster than their x86
counterparts probably the best answer to
this is depends on what you're doing
when m1 launched almost two years ago
most of the software was still not
optimized for this new architecture and
apple created the rosetta app to convert
old legacy applications to run
seamlessly with the new m1 format
but the real performance boost really
happens when the software is fully
optimized to run on the m1 technology
for example
in the video editing world
final cut pro and davinci resolve and
premiere pro they all
now have new versions to support soc
natively without using rosetta
and this actually gives you pretty
amazing results
especially for video encoding and
real-time previewing
like when you're editing and skimming
footage in a timeline
even at really really high resolutions
i use this m1 pro for editing a
documentary style video on my
architectural thesis project which i
released a couple weeks ago
and this was all very high quality
footage that we shot in venice
and the the editing was incredibly
smooth and
i could watch the footage in real time
and the rendering
the final export
took less than three minutes if you're
interested in watching this video i'll
leave the link right here it's a really
interesting video also i was able to
edit an 8k h.265
spherical video
on premiere pro
with the preview in full resolution with
like camera projections applied onto it
in real time on an older system i would
have probably had to decrease the
resolution to about a quarter to keep
the editing relatively smooth in a
nutshell to
fully take advantage of the m1 processor
you really need to have a software
that's optimized for the m1
when it comes to the architecture
industry which is already pretty heavily
pc based
this is not always the case
here's the list of software used in the
industry that's compatible with either
m1 or emulated via rosetta but this
doesn't necessarily mean that the
architecture software doesn't work or
that it doesn't work well on an m1
computer what i'm trying to say is that
the performance of an m1 is not
necessarily going to outperform other
x86 based systems of the same price
range and in fact in some cases the
performance is going to be good or just
meet the average
and if you're looking for technical
details or benchmarks there's tons of
other videos that you can find online
and i will not be doing that today
archicad sketchup revit rhino and lots
of other industry standard software they
all rely on x86
and in a lot of cases they're meant to
run with dedicated gpus revit for
example which is of course the industry
standard bim modeling software it was
never released on macs to run it on an
apple system you have to use it uh on a
virtual machine um like on a parallel or
use an older macbook which has like an
intel cpu with bootcamp when the
software is emulated the level of
performance is is also dependent on the
rosetta app and and the app's ability to
translate the software onto the m1 which
could also improve over time in one of
my previous videos i did do a brief
walkthrough of the different
architectural softwares on the m1 air i
haven't spent too much time playing
around with the software on this
computer yet but let me know if you want
me to do a similar walkthrough on the m1
pro as well
if you're using a laptop for
architecture and you just need to get
things done quickly without worrying
about compatibility
choosing a windows based laptop with
either an intel or amd last generation
processor with an accelerated gpu
is probably your safest option in terms
of architecture software compatibility
for example amd with ryzen 9 59 hx
series and intel with the new core i7
11800h
and core i9 11 980 hk are finally
providing pretty good alternatives in
the x86 world at a pretty competitive
price there's also lots of laptop models
out there using these chips personally i
still use my dell laptop which runs on
an intel processor for most of my
professional architecture work i almost
use my m1 exclusively for digital
imaging and video editing work
i think for creative professionals and
youtubers these are uh incredible
machines i also recently got an ipad pro
m1 and i freaking love
using this for sketching and designing
and i've been experimenting with
procreate
and i think this is actually a game
changer for architect the tablet's also
really great as an extension of my
laptop because i can very easily import
and export sketches
uh between the two and i can also use my
ipad as a second screen with scikar i'll
make a series of videos about sketching
and procreate so yeah stay tuned
so it seems to me that the soc is
probably going to be the new
computational standard that apple's
going to be implementing in all of their
products with all of these new features
packed into one single low-powered
component i wouldn't even be surprised
if they came up with a new
like standalone augmented reality goggle
becoming a part of their ecosystem at
some point like i mentioned before we're
the m1 excels and pretty much destroys
the competition is the power efficiency
and the performance per watt the power
usage on these computers are so
efficient that it makes working on site
or working remotely a real breeze
for example if i'm on a construction
site all day i can bring my laptop for
like panning around the model or looking
at drawings without
worrying about power and with the m2
coming soon this is just gonna get
better
if you're an architect and you use your
laptop every day for work
as well as for your side projects the
answer is probably
not just yet if you're not able to fully
take advantage of it doesn't really seem
like the best choice especially nowadays
where you can get a really good intel or
amd alternative at almost half the price
but
as soon as companies like autodesk or
graphisoft or vectorworks start making
fully optimized versions of their
software to run on the m1
this is gonna change really really fast
based on my personal experience so far
the m1 is a great companion laptop where
i can do all of my other creative work i
use adobe creative cloud on it and i
basically run my full video production
studio on this little computer i i know
it is a bit of luxury but i love having
the ability to keep my daily work and my
creative work on two separate systems so
that i can avoid idle time and i can
even run renderings while i'm making
videos on my m1
i know that a lot of you viewers are
students
and i know lots of you have been asking
me about whether you buy a macbook or
not and i think i
know what you want to hear
but i do think that for anyone just
starting their architecture journey
you should buy a machine that can run
all of the software without any problems
as a young architect your usage of
software
is going to be your superpower i think
it's really important for you to be able
to learn different programs because in a
lot of cases
for that entry level position
knowing revit or knowing autocad or
whatever the software is
that is gonna be the difference between
you getting hired and not getting hired
also you're probably gonna have a bit of
a tighter budget
uh so getting an intel or amd based
laptop will save you money and time
especially if you're planning to keep
your laptop running on a power supply
most of the time and portability is not
really your priority
there's a lot of gaming laptops that
don't look as great
that but have excellent rendering
performance and powerful gpu the only
downside is that they're not a slick and
they can be really really noisy when the
cpu is getting stressed feel free guys
to nerd me out with your best
architecture laptop configurations i had
a chance to use an asus rock with the
ryzen 4800h
and it was kind of like being next to an
airplane when i was doing video
renderings but
definitely it got the job done for now i
think the m1 pro is
an amazing machine
but
mainly focused on high-end creative
professionals
and that's i think where it excels the
most thanks for watching guys i hope
this video was helpful
and let me know if you want me to make a
dedicated video where i test out all of
the standard software on this machine
let me know if you like this video and
if you want me to make more in-depth
reviews of laptops if you want to check
out my review of the m1 air i will leave
it right here and don't forget to like
and subscribe and hit the bell if you
want to get notified when i release a
new video
and if you have any suggestions about
what laptop or software i should try to
make a video about next leave it in the
comments below
thanks for watching guys and i'll see in
the next video bye
[Music]
you